welcome welcome to this video playing
angelina 5 118 really no name yeah might
might be a woman might not be you never
know ok we have a queen Queens pawn
opening some very interesting a 4b 4c
for heavy fibers a normal move but
they're not sure I know that kind of
setup and wondering maybe I can play
with Bishop d7 95 C 5 mm yeah he or she
might play d5 yeah my night age for this
kind of idea then it's um it's fairly
typical but in this position there is no
Knight c3 available which is the normal
way to play so there will be a porn at
the end of this
mmm I go h6 takes takes Bishop takes
that's a double attack against the night
on H fried the rook and don't really
understand it maybe I'm overlooking
something but this looks um looks okay
for me doesn't it okay he just retreated
and the text c5 yeah okay that's
protected I one idea here is not a 67
and tried to just win this pawn whenever
it were native when he takes I mean he
must take at some point and 94 I don't
understand much she metaphorically King
the rook taking the Queen I'm just
taking the rock buddy or whatever thing
buddy is maybe wrong wrong expression
maybe was really a sign yeah this was a
disaster really not sure I mean if this
let's let's go through this b5 is an
interesting move it's the prescribed
antidote against g3 here to prevent c4
normally it turn it goes like this and
then Bishop g5 or castle sometimes white
go sees recurring b3 this kind of ideas
okay plate for she played a 4b 4c form
yeah yeah I'm not sure that this is good
but it looks like
looks like a normal way to play and I'm
not sure that this is really good now
because in comparable positions you
always have Knight c3 and you don't have
this year so maybe this isn't so great
94 94 was a direct a direct way to play
the point is if white takes I can take
him check yeah another problem with the
setup it's a however however if you look
at this hmm i can i can go back white
gets many many 10pm really messy 94 was
interesting as well but okay i was just
playing normal moves and this I think is
just not working I mean taking it's just
a double attack why can take here but I
was thinking that just knight c6 would
be sufficient
and I also if white plays something like
that i'm going to take here not on a one
this is more more valuable also
weakening the kingside whites King side
yeah this I don't know this does not
work at all just just lose this outright
bit of a bit of a weird game was an
opening an opening misstep by white
alright thanks for watching